McDonalds is everywhere.
In the contiguous United States, the farthest
you can get from one is this spot in the Sheldon
National Antelope Refuge in Nevada.
Even then, you only have to drive 115 miles
to the nearest golden arches.
Around there world, there are more than 36,000
locations in 119 different countries.
One of the defining characteristics of McDonald’s
is the commitment to consistency across the
brand.
While there are regional differences to the
menu such as KiwiBurgers in New Zealand or
Chicken Congee in Indonesia, the core menu
items such as Big Macs, Chicken Nuggets, and
Fries are always avaliable.
That means that the same items are being made
in the same way with the same ingredients
in very different economies around the world.
Obviously, BigMacs don’t cost the same everywhere.
A Big Mac costs on average $4.79 in the US,
so if you were to charge the equivalent in
Kenya, 480 Shilling, nobody would buy it because
that’s double the average daily salary.
That’d be like charging $200 for a big mac
in the US.
That’s why McDonald’s sets the local price
for burgers based on a variety of factors
such as labor costs, rent, ingredient costs,
and local income levels.
Now for some real economics.
Purchasing Power is the amount of goods you
can get for one unit of currency.
Let me explain.
In the US, the average price of a Big Mac
across all markets is $4.79.
In Sweden, the cost of a BigMac is 44 krona.
44 Krona is equivalent to $5.13.
That means that in the US, you can get 20.8%
of a BigMac for a dollar, while in Sweden,
you can only get 19.5% of that burger.
So, in terms of the BigMac, the purchasing
power of the US dollar is higher.
You get more bang for your buck.
This also means that the Swedish Krona is
overvalued in terms of exchange rates by about
6.1%, at least according to the Big Mac Index.
The Economist Magazine first created the index
in 1986 as an informal way of comparing Purchasing
Power between currencies.
So now let’s look at the numbers.
In Venezuela, the cost of a BigMac is equivalent
to $0.66—that’s the cheapest Big Mac in
terms of equivalent US dollars in the world.
This is in largely due to recent currency
devaluations and high inflation in the country.
It’s possible that the cost of a Venezuelan
Big Mac will soon rise in response.
This means that for the cost of one American
Big Mac, you could buy 7 Venezuelan Big Macs.
After Venezuela, the countries with the cheapest
Big Macs are Russia, Ukraine, South Africa,
and Malaysia.
For the other side of the spectrum, the top
five most expensive big macs come from Switzerland,
Sweden, Norway, the US, then Denmark.
That’s right, the US is home to the fourth
most expensive Big Mac in the world.
What’s also interesting is to look at how
long it takes individuals to earn enough money
to buy a BigMac in different cities around
the world.
In Nairobi, Kenya, an average worker would
have to rack up 173 minutes on the clock to
pay for one Big Mac.
Compare that to an worker in Hong Kong, who
would only have to work 8.7 minutes for a
burger.
The quickest one can earn a burger in the
US is in Miami, where the average individual
would only have to work for 10.7 minutes to
pay for a Big Mac.
Now, this index isn’t perfect.
While the cost of ingredients is pretty similar
across all countries since all ingredients
are held to the same standard, the index doesn’t
account for the wide differences in labor
and land costs.
A burger will cost less to make in India because
McDonald’s doesn’t need to pay as much
for employees and retail space.
Nevertheless, this index is a great way of
teaching some basic economics in a tasty way.
I hope you enjoyed this week’s episode.
Last week I covered timekeeping on Mars which
you can find here.
If you enjoy these videos, make sure to click
subscribe here.
Also, please follow me on Twitter @WendoverPro.
Thanks for watching, and see you next Tuesday
with more of That Wikipedia List.